مساء الفل ليه حياتنا الماليه فيها فوضى
ومش متظبطه احد اكبر الاسباب الرئيسيه في
ده هو اننا ما عندناش ميزانيه شخصيه او
ميزانيه منزل بيرسون الميزانيه الشخصيه هي
خطه ماليه مكتوبه بتتكون من حاجتين الدخل
هو اي جنيه بيدخل جيبك سواء جاي من وظيفه
او بيزنس او ماجر حاجه شقه محل عربيه الى
اخره والحاجه التانيه هي النفقات وهي كل
جنيه بيخرج من جيبك سواء بقى ايجار شقه
قسط عربيه مصارفك لاستهلاكيه المعتاده زي
الاكل والمواصلات والعلاج الى اخره لازم
تسجل كل ده استخدم اي تطبيق من التطبيقات
اللي بتعمل ده وسجل فيها التفاصيل دي
الميزانيه هي اللي بتسمح لك تحدد ازاي
وفين تصرف فلوسك وتعمل تتبع للانفاق ده
وهي اللي هتكشف سلوكياتك الماليه وبالتالي
تقدر تعالج الخلل اللي فيها وهي اللي
هتمنعك تراكم الديون عليك لانها هتسمح لك
بالسيطره على نفقاتك ما تنسوش تشتركوا في
قناه المخ والاقتصادي على اليوتيوب علشان
تتابعوا حلقتنا